unfortunately hate crimes just like tony
said are becoming more and more common
in america the center for the study of
hate and extremism at california state
university san bernardino found hate
crimes are up 26 percent so far this
year across 16 major u.s cities we are
joined now by former u.s attorney
general eric holder his new book our
unfinished march is about the battle to
protecting voting rights good morning
mr attorney general why do you believe
hate crimes are climbing up in this
country
well you know this is something that has
inflicted the as has afflicted this
nation almost since the beginning
of our country as a republic it's
something that we've seen rise in recent
years as we see demographic changes as
we see economic dislocation as we see
rhetoric coming from political uh parts
of of of our nation these are all the
kinds of things that i think give rise
to this kind of this kind of hate part
of our history as well as the current
political environment in which we find
ourselves
and so here we sit mr holder today
everybody's longing for answers right
now we're in that painful and disgusting
cycle i believe what steve hartman once
called mourn pray repeat we've heard
this story we know how this goes it will
continue is there anything realistically
that can be done you know the newtown
shooting of all those school children
happened under your watch so to speak
under the obama administration and
everybody thought this is it this is a
turning point is there anything
realistically that can be done to stop
this kind of thing
yeah i mean there are some common sense
things that i think that we can do if we
had our leaders listen to the people of
this nation we certainly would have done
something after newtown
we see the american people who support
no
regular normal sane gun safety measures
those need to be put in place i think
also given the rise in
in hate crimes racial and ethnic driven
hate crimes we need to think about the
imposition of a domestic terrorism
statute it has to be finally drawn in
such a way that respects uh people's
first amendment rights
we need to enhance the ability of the
atf to do a whole range of regulatory
things i went to to confirm steve
denlbach as the head of the al bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms and then i
think also we need to have a
conversation and i'm not sure how that
gets structured uh were people who run
social media companies um they are the
purveyors of a lot of this hate it is
through their um their platforms that
people get radicalized and so coming up
with ways in which tech they use the
technology that they have to kind of
identify people
stop the spread of this kind of hateful
information i think if you do all of
those kinds of things you perhaps can
get start to get a handle on this this
very serious problem
don't the people have to speak up though
and say we want this done i know we keep
saying we care about it but i just think
where is the outrage of people saying to
the people in power to say you've got to
do something about this i believe in
first amendment rights too of course but
it come first amendment rights comes
with some responsibility
and i never that always seems to be
missing to me in this conversation
well the interesting thing gail is that
the people have spoken in poll after
poll
they indicate that they want background
checks for instance before anybody has
the ability to buy um a weapon uh and
what we see is because of gerrymandering
in the state legislatures especially the
ability of the people to have their will
put into policy is frustrated
people in these representatives in these
safe these gerrymandered seats can do
things that are consistent with the
desires of the gun lobby inconsistent
with the desires of their constituents
and yet they suffer no electoral
consequence and so political involvement
is something by the people that is is
going to have to be a critical part of
this effort
eric holder thank you it's so
frustrating you're right about that girl
so frustrating